from fancy PBS comes a show that takes
place anywhere in the universe at any
time in the past present or future where
anything can happen and none of the
continuity matters Doctor Who get ready
for a continuation of the original
series that picks up after 16 years off
the air because all the British nerds
who grew up with classic who finally got
old enough to call the shots at the BBC
now they're taking the stodgy old
formula and stretching it to an hour of
quirky comedy to know who you are
improved special effects and enough soap
opera pop to choke a telenovela - you
need a doctor
okay dr. Kidd meet the doctor he's not
an actual doctor but an alien who named
himself that Isabel the name I chose is
the doctor it's like a promise you make
even though the word doctor was created
to describe him
the word for healer and wise man we kept
that word from you you know yeah that's
not the first paradox you're gonna have
to swallow paradox how the dog's heart
turned up peridot peridot peridot
paradox two fans he's a two hearted Time
Lord who hijacked a faulty TARDIS from
the planet Gallifrey who sometimes kind
of a dick funny little human brains
how'd he get around in those things with
the casual viewers he's a funny man with
the time machine who takes ladies on
adventures who's also kind of a dick
satis time
watch him - through time equipped with a
sonic screwdriver and psychic paper
- devices with the power to speed up the
plot is dead and the TARDIS everything a
time machine with the power to break
when the plot needs to slow down stop
maybe they break less we didn't keep
exploding inside of it it's just a
thought watch the spatial justice
warrior travel all around the known
universe from the streets of London to
working-class British mining towns to
the quaintest middle english villages
just other people know they're very all
people but when the budget allows he'll
fly off to the far reaches of the CGI
universe where everything is still
extremely brutish starship UK its
Britain yes the Sun never sets on the
British Empire her sons
all the sons by his side as always is
his trusty companion usually a cute girl
because ratings who after a few seasons
of adventure usually has her life ruined
and they were tortured my mum my dad the
sister if she's lucky
she'll follow law to keep the doctor
grounded give him someone to talk to and
act as is mostly platonic but not always
love interest no they're basically
dating without the sex
except for nardole that one was purely
physical I'm not just sexy experienced a
franchise that's been running for so
long
they built 13 Reid castings of the main
character into the lore then hit that
limit and pulled even more out of a
crack as each actor brings a new spin to
the alien who's seen the stars but looks
like he's never seen the Sun whether
it's EKKO stood the only doctor of the
modern era to regenerate due to creative
differences with a BBC David Tennant the
unquestioned master of steering sadly
into the middle distance
[Music]
Matt Smith who combined the face of a
handsome 12 year old with the way the
arms of an inflatable tube man Peter
Capaldi who reimagined the doctor as
your uncle who never got married and
moved to Vegas in his 40s I was being
hauled down by the cuts at a to notice
or Jodie Whittaker the first female
doctor which no matter how she performs
is one of the least outrageous things
this ridiculous show has ever done but
an all-powerful hero demands all
powerful villains to go up against and
the doctor has some because in plenty of
episodes it's a lame monster of the week
invasion of the very small queues or
something invisible to save on the
effects budget or something we've seen a
million times before but an alien or
Nene still some evildoers are among the
best in sci-fi like the Cybermen
emotionless robots who can only be
defeated by feelings the master a
renegade Time Lord who considers
themselves the doctors arch-nemesis but
is in the middle of this list so you do
the math the weeping angels killer stone
statues who get less threatening with
every appearance until they're about as
scary as ghostbusters 2 the doctors
greatest rival Christmas
and the doctors other greatest rival the
Daleks rushy blob stuffed into cramped
metal homes who spend their entire life
shouting commands and people they hate
so internet commoners can't talk now
follow along when the series spanning
arcs that would delight fans and confuse
newcomers like the seasons where the
world keeps ending well just kidding it
can reverse the planets rotation like
Superman cannot restore the seasons
where the doctor falls in love with his
companion only to lose her for all
eternity
just kidding he'll make a copy of
himself and they'll live happily ever
after
the seasons where the doctor copes with
the inevitability of his own death I'm
dying
JK Rowling he'll live as long as the
show needs him to what I suppose one
more lifetime or the seasons where he's
haunted by the knowledge that he's
triggered the genocide of his own people
no cop genocide you see now picture me
that or maybe he's just kidding and he
actually saved everyone but doesn't
remember it
no actually suggesting that we change
our own personal history sure that'll
work
wibbly-wobbly timey-wimey whatever so
run now your nearest hallway
pull a plan ahead of yours but I've got
a plan hi
I've got a plan yeah of course I have a
plan and starts spouting techno babble
like the universe depends on it wave a
fan Cassadine energy macro transmission
of a cake build a wave that sticks it
into a living receptacle minute feeds
off the remaining auction energy because
you're about to get some of the greatest
standalone episodes in sci-fi history
with a bunch of momentum killing
serialization crammed into service the
diehards but after all is said and done
let's still try to be more like the
doctor never cruel or cowardly never be
cruel never be cowardly just enjoy the
ride Inlet who do who know Frodo old foe
toto no Bo oh so cold don't know so well
coach oh geez you make it hard to love
you sometimes starring the leftover bad
wolf bad wolf what you cannot do
scary poppins show me your Bo face the
appearance of the repeated meme save
Martha just the Tim Harry and Ron at the
same time 12 angry man I want a girl
with a short skirt in the long jacket
the mrs. Frizzle dudes just kind of
there of we Billy Nooyi master of none
spin-doctors the great glass doctor
vader hood that time Rose was on weakest
link you not a cent
oh my god they killed Rory you bastards
you'll die yeah twice sorry Rory but you
just died the gravestone here is one
with the same name as me that thing
tenets voice does every British actor
Harry Potter division
every British actor came of thrones
division
every British actor came of Thrones and
harrypotter division
every other British actor every British
historical figure in charge of Queen
Victoria I get that Christy don't
William Shakespeare extremely long
vigils I will guard this body for a
thousand years 36 years three months
four days of solitary confinement hello
four and a half billion years and Doctor
Who Doctor Who Doctor Who Doctor Who
Doctor Who Doctor Who Doctor Who Doctor
Days of Our Lives of Future Passed whew
that was a lot of who to get through it
wasn't so bad now let's see what that
classic series is all about new timeline
new timeline
want to see where the adventures of the
doctor all began then click above to see
our trailer for classic Doctor Who
spanning decades of television that
happened before the reboot grab a jelly
baby and check it out it's Affairs I
wear a fez now fezzes are cool it's more
like a big ball of wibbly-wobbly
timey-wimey stuff